this looks this looks weird right how do
we go about this first I want you to see
the parallels between this and this
right it might be easier if I put on if
I put a 1 there okay
I just want you to look at that store it
in the back of your mind and now let's
follow the instructions they're giving
us okay express this as this so clearly
that a the big they're designated to us
is this X plus 3x squared business okay
so if I take that I can expand it I can
even use this notation that I've just
developed okay that's going to be equal
to let's write it out in a few steps
there's the X plus 3x squared it's about
6 ok sir I'm gonna need the next line we
need as much movie like am I'm going to
use my NCR notation right so I'm gonna
have an C 0 right plus and C 1 okay what
happens next
think of my general term it's this ^ R
which in this case is just 1 yep is that
okay see that's my that's my that's my
whole term bit if you like it's my a all
right so there's a in there okay it's
writing the whole thing up okay I've got
to go to the next term and that's gonna
be mc2 and then I'm gonna have X plus 3
x squared squared because it matches and
their ship write it out as far as X to
the power of 3 so there is the 3 and
that's okay now I'm not pause for a
second sorry
thank you okay now before we go on why
on earth would they ask you to just stop
because it's not actually equal to that
right this this is not true right this
is something else I can't say equals
right but I can't say something
uh-oh work out what to put here in a
second okay it's not equal because I'm
missing the 2 power 4 and the power 5
and a power 6 so there are some terms
over here that the textbook is just
telling me about
now the question is why don't I need
them well there's a couple of reasons no
one there's some symmetry okay but well
that can't be a problem for me right
like if I if I just take any old terms
okay if I said if I went to this right
and if I just pick some arbitrary four
okay you know just um just take the
first half because that's what the first
you know two up to par three just take
those right
I just just don't worry about that don't
we're done it's okay right this is a
major problem for us this is not true
right
have a look at this got one plus pi of
the power of three okay what is this
this is like four point something four
point one four one five etc to power
three so something above sixty four
because that's more cute right it's a 64
65 ish right well they just rub off
these terms
65 not even close so on what grounds
could I or the text would you say just
well I'll show you let me come back to
this right and what its connection is to
this vid number right can you see
there's a 1 and a 1 and a 3 like there's
a 1 a 1 and a 3 sir just like I did over
here right the difference between this
and this is that this is this when X has
assumed a certain value right just like
this is this when X is assumed a certain
value so then the question becomes well
what value of x should I choose and you
might be able to even see it there right
the value of x I want is gonna be
something that gives me 1 plus 0.01
right plus 0.003 which of course I could
just write as 1 plus 0.01 plus 3 times
0.01 square
whoops sorry yeah that's right it's 1%
of 1% which is yeah point zero zero zero
one percent yeah okay um all right so I
choose any value of x just like I chose
a value of x very heat Mississippi we're
Frost
we're not used to oh you you choose your
own adventure pick whatever value of x
for one okay but you can see why it's
gonna be useful to us and now you can
see why I can just start ignoring values
can you see why okay what is X X is 0.01
so as I go off in this direction think
about what these numbers are actually
staying to equal now okay so let's have
a look at this one I know what this is
it shouldn't be an N it should be a six
shouldn't it because that's what and I
should say six actually say six so we
are we stated before that anything see
zebra is gonna be one right the next one
along cuz it's the service the road is
gonna be six okay
and then I've got now what is this thing
it's zero point zero one zero three full
stop right then you got this guy 6c -
okay what's the next term alone the
fifteen is a 56 see - yeah my memory is
not that bad okay 50 next time 50 and
then I'll have zero point zero one zero
three you can see what's happening now
as I go this way right what's gonna
happen to zero point zero one zero and
three to the power of four don't have
five it has 60 this tiny insignificant
thing right and so that's why I can say
well if you drop off those terms that's
okay you'll still roughly be equal
okay because what I'm dropping off are
these trivial terms okay so that's why I
can start so I'm approximately equal to
this is going to be an approximation
I need my last term here 63 what is it
is a 20 no it's bigger what is it
63 money honey is it 20 please 2000-2001
0-1-0-3
huge okay and then I stop there and that
you can evaluate okay so yeah so you see
how there's a lot of layers to this